former Vice President Joe Biden won big
in Democratic contest last night all
across the country took Michigan with
125 delegates took that state by double
digits
Biden also won Missouri Mississippi and
Idaho Washington and North Dakota as of
this moment are too close to call
but Biden now leads senator Bernie
Sanders by a hundred and fifty delegates
822 670 that makes for a difficult road
ahead for the Sanders campaign on
Instagram a leading Sanders supporter
congressman Alexandria Ocasio Cortes
said there's no sugarcoating it it's a
tough night CBS News political
contributors Robby Mook and Terry
Sullivan are here with what this means
for the two candidates
Robbie was Hillary's Clinton Hillary
Clinton's 2016 campaign manager Terry
was Marco Rubio's campaign manager four
years ago welcome to you both again
Robbie Michigan was kind of critical for
you four years ago you remember
painfully I'm sure cuz Bernie Bernie
Sanders won Michigan four years ago so
what does this say that that that he
lost so big this time around yeah look
it's it's a big symbolic loss for him it
was a big symbolic win last time I will
point out in 2016 you only won by a
point like it was a landslide yes I'm so
I actually was concerned for him that
expectations were set really high you
know he was he's been underperforming
2016 all of a sudden had to over perform
there he is he has made two statements
continuously throughout this campaign
I'm gonna win white working-class voters
and I'm gonna have big turnout that's
gonna transform the electorate we just
haven't seen either and and we saw his
support correlated with lower turnout on
Super Tuesday and Michigan was a blow to
the white working-class are you yeah a
lot of people are still wowed back by
this comeback by Biden what's what's
behind those turnaround you know we and
we talked about this after Super Tuesday
you had Buddha judge and Klobuchar and
beta O'Rourke come out before Super
Tuesday they brought up the biggest bat
signal they could and said this is the
winner and Democrats are starved to win
this game and I wouldn't I wouldn't
underestimate his campaign I mean his
campaign staff has taken a lot of heat
by members of supporters of of the vice
president but they've done a good job I
mean they're not here on accident this
is not luck and and happenstance they
ran a good campaign and it paid off and
and just quickly say Biden was pulling
ahead in all these states for a long
time just there was a rough patch so in
some ways it just returned to the norm
Biden picked up a key endorsement from a
mayor in a County that Trump won after
Obama had won it twice so you had an
Obama to trump now back to the Democrats
could we see more of that that's really
key for a victory look I think you're
gonna see it in in going both directions
I think you're going to see you know
Republicans endorsing Democrats and vice
versa
really I do because I see Turkey well I
mean that's the political environment
we're in now I mean it is so much more
personality driven than it is
ideologically anymore it's about do you
like this person can you identify with
this person you see that with people
switching from Bernie Sanders to Joe
Biden there's a fundamental ideological
difference but they but it's about
personality who they like and who they
don't like
after these results Robby how tough is
the math for Bernie Sanders is this race
effectively over it's it's tough I
believe in two ways first of all that
delicately it's gotten over a hundred
and once you're into triple digits it's
just it's basically impossible to catch
up but the other problem for Bernie is
this next contest on the 17th
I think it's be really hard these are
states that Hillary won yeah these are
states I don't see any reason why he's
going to somehow pull ahead and so I
think the decision he's facing is
soldier on and potentially face it worse
not you think you'll do I don't know I
don't I also don't think as Democrats we
need to just apply a ton of pressure
it's March there's some time I I do
think Biden and we saw Biden do this
last night he has got to welcome and I
would say all candidates supporters
right I think we can we shouldn't we
shouldn't just talk about Bernie
supporters we shall talk well Elizabeth
Warren supporters and other people's
supporters as well but you know there's
time and I think the most important
thing is back off let Bernie that's
that's that's a sign right there
for Democrats that this is over when
when when Robbie says oh there's time
there's nothing to force him out that
means he's a zombie candidate it's over
for him functionally you know whether he
knows it or not
yeah well Terry the stock market has
really taken a dive or took a dive what
days ago how might this affect the
president's reelection efforts
yeah I mean this is not a good thing for
Donald Trump I mean this this the
largely due to the coronavirus this is
is the unforeseeable that he's having a
deal
and he's gotten mixed reviews at best
not only with with how he's dealing with
the economy but but but with the know
they're so intertwined though I mean
that one the it's you know nothing is
fundamentally shift in the economy over
the last week other than the coronavirus
rights defied political conventions
before though people would write you
know you think this is a coronavirus
categorically different from the many
things that he's ducked before oh I
don't know anybody who tells you they do
know is lying to you because who knows I
mean look the the reports of his death
have been premature a few times before
and everyone says oh this is the camels
you know that's wrong the camel's back
maybe it is maybe it isn't
yeah right Biden senators of both camps
have both canceled rallies yesterday the
president Trump has not I was gonna say
I think this is really interesting
Donald Trump feeds off those rallies
those are how he came to to you know
become the nominee of the of the
Republican Party and then and then the
president he feeds off of those more
than anything else yeah if if they take
away the rallies from him it's gonna be
interesting what that does to his psyche
and his candidacy at what point will
they I mean will someone just have to
stop and say hey this is a 73 year old
billionaires generally don't change
their mind and people have tried to tell
Donald Trump to stop doing stuff before
it hasn't gone so well for them Robbie
Bernie Sanders has been saying that the
political establishment is the reason
why Joe Biden is rising and he is not
you are a representative of the
establishment here as the former
campaign manager for Hillary Clinton
what is your reaction to that you know
look I I think a lot of rhetoric is
swung around both ways on this campaign
IIIi think the at some point the voters
are just speaking right it's just voters
rank-and-file voters and people in the
so-called establishment which I think
it's a bit of a mirage but let's go with
it for a second you know sure might be
might be favoring Biden over Bernie but
at some point you got to look at those
votes and and I think that's I think
that's his core problem look the other
thing I will say that I noticed last
night which will have impact for the
general election these
huge turnout we're seeing in the suburbs
it really went strong for Hillary we're
absolutely the reason we went back the
house to turnout surge that we're seeing
in those areas is massive and I I think
the question for Trump is gonna be can
he counteract that with turnout in more
rural areas that's a big question moving
forward gentlemen good to see you both
goodsoon here again soon
yeah thank you